hello all as promised and my mother
spoiler-free review which I do have this
is my video that are my thoughts on the
movie mother the interpretation that I
saw in it basically my spoiler top which
is a solid spoiler warning if you want
to watch this movie you don't want
spoilers don't watch those if you have
seen it or you don't care well hell [ __ ]
you've been warned so here we go let's
talk about mug what do you think about
mother I feel like it is pretty
straightforward at least what I saw I
could be completely wrong in my
interpretation but this is what I see in
mother mother is the story of God mother
earth the earth itself and humanity a
lot of it representative of biblical
stories and humanity in general the
movie starts out you see someone amidst
a fire then Javier Bardem puts this
crystal on this mount and this house
comes back to life and then Jennifer
Lawrence literally forms in the bed and
springs to life and I was like I think I
know where this movie was going yeah
Javier Bardem is gone Jennifer Lawrence
is Mother Earth they play a married
couple the house she's painting their
utopia that's Earth and all the other
human beings in the movie they're human
beings a humanity in one way shape or
form which also makes sense they barge
into their house they spring onto the
earth scenes start treating it like it's
their own during truce if we putting
their feet up on the counters and [ __ ]
she's like what are you doing can you
not smoke in the house can you not sit
on the counter all the people treat her
house like it's their house they're
being very rude they're like rude guests
which if there is a mother earth that's
how she would see humanity however
Javier Bardem characters thinks they're
great he wants camaraderie he wants
companionship with these new people
which makes him neglect her and her
needs because the belief is if there is
a God then it's God in humans and
they're all tight like that which is
perfect to make a metaphorical God and a
metaphorical mother earth married in
this movie because the concepts of those
two are completely conflicting I mean if
the Bible's correct then God's all about
human beings and human beings are all
about themselves and they're trashing
the earth in the process ergo God is not
all about the earth which if there is a
mother earth would make her very pissed
at him perfect marriage Michelle
Pfeiffer and Ed Harris are the first
human beings to step into their house
the first human beings to step into this
earth metaphor and that that would make
them Adam and Eve I also believe that
they're representative of more than just
Adam and Eve and the section of humanity
as a whole but I believe there Adam and
Eve not just because they have a Cain
and Abel metaphor a little later in the
movie and they are the first human
beings you see but also there's this
wound in Ed Harris's side that you see
in one scenery's thrown up in the toilet
and the Bible says Eve was
created from a rib from Adam so he would
have a wound in his side you also find
out Javier Bardem as a writer and Edie
Harris as characters like oh I'm a huge
fan your book changed my life which is
what a lot of people say about the Bible
so he's talking about the Bible at this
point I believe it's just the Old
Testament and there might be a party
that says that doesn't make complete
sense because at the time of Adam and
Eve there was no Bible maybe just look
at the story there would be no one to
write it I mean it's kind of comparable
to Thorin Oakenshield going to build the
Baggins during The Hobbit and be like
hey man loved the book when those
current events happening at that moment
or actually what the book is going to be
about the book that's not even written
yet but again with metaphors you can
kind of like fudge lines in benthic
lovely thing about metaphors they don't
lock you in a box there's even that room
with that little crystal that Ed Harris
and Michelle Pfeiffer they're not
supposed to go in there they're not
supposed to touch this thing and when
they do they break it and Javier Bardem
gets pissed he's like leave representing
the moment Adam and Eve got kicked out
of the Garden of Eden I also really like
the part at a point in the movie when
more people start coming into their
house some people just start painting
her walls and she's like what are you
doing why are you paying the wall to
like oh we're helping you just like I
don't want you to help me can you please
stop that if there was a Mother Earth
I'm sure she'd be like I don't want that
and you please just stop being you but
at a point when more people start coming
into this house ed Harris and Michelle
Pfeiffer's kids come into the house they
get into a scuffle they start throwing
[ __ ] around at first I was like oh
that's just humanity fighting maybe it's
a war maybe it's representative of world
war one then one kills the other one and
he said it's because they loved him most
and I was like oh or Cain and Abel
metaphor I lean towards Cain and Abel
metaphor more than a world war metaphor
because at this point you'll see later
on Javier Bardem writes another book
which I think is the New Testament so
we're dealing with Old Testament
timeline right here they are the kids of
the metaphorical Adam and Eve ergo that
would make them gain in Abel and one
kills the other one did in the funeral a
bunch of people start pouring in again
more people means more destruction the
house is getting wrecked a little more
more people are wrecking the earth
there's people on the counter they start
bouncing on the counter she's like can
you please stop that's not mounted they
bounce more she's like can you please
talk to like it's fine and they bust the
counter water sprays everywhere she
screams out him get the [ __ ] out of my
house and they do they all leave funny
thing about that water is spraying
everywhere and after that scene Javier
Bardem looking outside and it's raining
which you could take as metaphor for the
flood which means up to this point this
entire movie has been a more Darren
Aronofsky s
telling of the last movie Darren
Aronofsky directed funny but at that
point Jennifer Lawrence gets pissed at
him and she's like you're ignoring me
you love these people more than you love
me
blast a baby in me so they do they have
sex she's like I am pregnant and he gets
such inspiration he writes another book
and people love this book people start
flooding to their house this I take as
the New Testament and this is where
everything kind of goes a bit shitty for
mother to her this axe becomes the
[ __ ] cluster bomb of the
shitstorm sweepstake bunch of people are
flooding in they love Javier Bardem s
character taking pictures with him
signed the books signed this picture
bless me more people are flooding in her
house is really getting wrecked people
are rip and [ __ ] off the wall it really
shows the boom and this last act had to
progress really fast because if you look
at the history of the world there's this
YouTube video I forgot what it is but
it's basically human population and it
just shows how human population recently
just went wow it's really interesting
and that's what the last act of this
movie is is that time frame publicist
shows that plays by Kristen Wiig which I
thought was pretty cool but I don't you
really see people are like he loves me
monster they're hurting each other for
his love they're hurting each other
because of like I hold him so close to
me that I will punch you in the face for
him then you see these eldest people who
are now blessing other people in his
name I mean the SWAT teams coming in
explosions are going off people are
dying people are getting messed up
people's love for Javier Bardem and his
work is resulting in them hurting and
killing each other then Jennifer
Lawrence gives birth to their son Jesus
metaphor it is the son of the
metaphorical God so make sense point is
she does not want this baby anywhere
near those people's people are gonna
destroy this kid she knows it at Javier
Bardem s character gets his hand on the
kid shows it to the people the people
pass him around and they end up killing
the kid they kill this baby this with
this infant they snap his own neck and
it freaked me out not only that she's
screaming she goes up to what looks like
this bloody mass that they have cut up
another eating they're eating the bits
of the baby but you know Sacrament body
of Christ thing it's brutal as much as
the baby is an obvious metaphor for
Jesus the baby could be just a metaphor
for one of the many resources Mother
Earth has and the apparent last resource
mankind takes and devours before Mother
Earth just snaps showing that we're
really writing our fate to our own
apocalypse and that the baby could be a
metaphor for petroleum for all I know
point is that scene does show Hugh
tendency to take something and devour it
in a total act of gluttony whether it be
for good intentions or not very
self-serving life mine mine mine
this shows that Mother Earth sees
humanity just all is equal she's like
all of you just destroyed my baby it
doesn't show oh but these ones had good
intentions all humanity looks just like
a bunch of kids scraping with claws
devouring that which is good that's how
it would look to a deity looking in on
humanity who didn't have seen when she
has had it with people and Javier Bardem
like God metaphor it's like we need to
forgive them we need to love them
because that's what the Bible says but
this whole thing is seen through her
eyes and she's like why they're
[ __ ] and when you see the movie
through her eyes when you see this
biblical timeline through the eyes of
Mother Earth people are really [ __ ]
horrific I'm sure through the eyes of
Mother Earth if she's looking at God and
the stories of the Bible I'm sure God
looks quite mad like just kind of crazy
basically an encounter at Farpoint in
Star Trek The Next Generation Q would
call Jennifer Lawrence from this movie
as a witness against mankind and the
case would probably be closed Rivas Lee
savaged child race right here and she
does she screams the house cracks in
half that's a catastrophic something she
even says when she's pregnant earlier on
in the movie she's turning to Javier
Bardem in a very nice way does something
like well I better prep for the
apocalypse what she's done then she
blows everything up she blows herself up
she blows the people up she burns the
house down but the next scene he's
carrying her burnt body and she's even
like what are you don't remember the
exact phrase but I do love the line
there's a line that really sticks out to
me she says something like and I'm
paraphrasing here but she says something
like I wish my love was enough and he
responds with something like it couldn't
be I'm a creator if it was enough I
wouldn't create any more
she's a pretty powerful thing if you
look at the God of the Bible he's
written very human he gets jealous he
has love he has emotion he has anger at
that point if he is an eternal being if
he is a creator he will always need and
want and it should never be enough
otherwise he'll stop creating powerful
I'm not gonna lie I mean he reaches into
her and pulls out her heart throughout
the movie you've seen when she touches
the wall of her house you see a heart
that's slowly going black it's her heart
he pulls it out he crushes it and it's
that crystal you saw at the very
beginning she withers away and he puts
the crystal on that same
and then boom the house springs back to
life and it's just like the beginning of
the movie except the girl in the bed is
no longer Jennifer Lawrence it's another
girl and she just leans up and says
something like babe and then it ends
same thing that happened Jennifer
Lawrence is always a loop where time is
but a loop a loose stitch in the
universe okay but I love that at a point
in this movie I was like I feel like
it's going to end with the very end
being the very beginning and it's all
going to be a loop and it was I was very
pleased with that my wants were
fulfilled at that point I think I think
it's the beginning the Big Bang and the
end is that when everything crushes in
on itself in the universe and bangs
again and everything happens again or is
it a loop on actual literal earth is
this another world out there is each
scenario when the loop happens again is
it on a different world and as Javier
Bardem god deity is bouncing around from
world to world recreating the same thing
hoping it's different but it's the same
it's just the nature of life forms or is
this story the world that predates ours
and at the end when the new girl the new
Mother Earth wakes up is that our earth
now is the story all right everyone this
is how it went down before don't make it
the same now we have thus far
that was a fun of this movie this movie
really hit me as much as it sounds like
it's some sort of beat you over the head
religious movie it's really not at all
but it was a very interesting
metaphorical story best I can describe
it it's like a chapter out of Sandman
Neil Gaiman's Sandman or something and
once I saw that and the metaphor clicked
for me I was into this movie or I could
be completely wrong this movie could be
a complete metaphor on the human immune
system for all I know virus is invading
the body the body be in the house which
if you look at human beings and the
earth were very parasitic anyway so that
comparison still does work admittedly I
do not know what the elixir is that
Jennifer Lawrence would drink in the
movement you'd have a cup of water and
she'd put this stuff in it and it would
kind of glow and she'd drink it and boy
she becomes pregnant she pours it down
the toilet don't know what it is she
would drink it whenever she was feeling
pain but I'd like to know your thoughts
of it these are my thoughts on mother
this is what I saw and mother this is
what resonated with me in mother it's
just fascinating filmmaking writing and
directing to me you see what I saw did
you see something different to me it
seems very cut and dry I feel like
there's no other way to interpret this
movie other than a god metaphor and a
mother earth metaphor and humanity
within destroying earth which is the
house but hey who knows maybe people can
open my eyes on comment section so
whatever you think about this movie
whatever you saw comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]